good evening and welcome to this meeting
of employment committee the first item
on the agenda is attendances
i have received apologies from counselor
london uh have you had any more
apologies alex
i have not received any other apologies
thank you
uh the minutes of the previous meetings
uh they agreed this is true and accurate
record
yeah i'll move that chair
thank you
uh
have we had any questions from the
public alex
and no questions have been received
thank you
i've not been informed of any urgent
business
so we'll move on now to the people
update
is that you angela
it is councillor bennett thank you um
myself and richard are going to do a
little bit of a double act for for this
one
um okay so well um what a year it's been
for all of us again um and the hr
service continues to respond to the
challenges of the pandemic and its
variances
and we have been supporting managers and
staff to develop their own skills
and maintain key services in the face of
these challenges that covered and now we
have a new variant omicron um
the challenges that they continue to
bring us
so we do know that our attendance levels
in some of our front-facing services in
particular have been impacted by the
conditions that continue to present
through covid
and we've been supporting in a number of
areas including fast-tracking of
recruitment for example
we've been supporting the community
events for our catering and cleaning
services so that any gaps in school
meals provision can be quickly addressed
and we've had some success in those
community recruitment events thus far
so we may we've also recently introduced
a tightening up of our vacancy
management process um
and so we're advertising all vacancies
internally first there are some
exceptions
and for our traded services as i've just
mentioned and our frontline social work
and care staff and those services like
for example star procurement
and gmss who are our hr colleagues who
are in partnership with others
um
so they are exempt from um the initial
first stage of advertising vacancies um
internally first
so the revised process is that myself in
the director of finance and systems will
approve any external advertisements by
exception
so our internal recruitment strategy is
still very much in line with our grow
our own talent strategy and this enables
our workforce to secure good career
opportunities that they that may then
present
entry-level options further down the
hierarchy and we're particularly going
to do some um initiatives around our
apprentices and our kickstart placements
and i'll talk more about that
further in the updates
so again we've produced um a
comprehensive three-month update of all
the things that the hr service are
continuing to do to support services to
still recover
from the pandemic and in some cases
continue to respond
um and it's important you know that
obviously the work that we're doing
ensures that our people do continue to
feel safe
and supported to be the best that they
can be while the conditions in which
we're all working continue to flux and
change
so as i mentioned earlier i've asked
richard to join us richard fontana he's
our health and safety strategic lead and
he's going to just take us through he's
going to update um on the work that
himself and the team are doing to keep
us safe and through our kofi challenges
and the gift of cozy just keeps on
giving doesn't it
so i'm going to hand over to richard now
and he's going to take us through the
health and safety update
thank you angela so yes just to give a a
health and safety overview in relation
to the the covid recovery as angela's
mentioned it has been an exceptionally
challenging time
in terms of keeping our
services
safe and assisting them in continuing to
deliver
the services
effectively on behalf of the council and
supporting our our communities going
forwards so
we do continue to work very closely um
both with the public health team and
collaboratively
with a range of services and teams
to protect our workforce and partners um
to ensure they do feel safe and we are
effectively managing
those risks of transmission uh and as
angel has mentioned particularly at the
current time as we're seeing um issues
with with the variant
it just makes it all the more important
that we do continue to reiterate the
measures that we have in place and
support our staff and services
so we do continue to have covert safe
measures in place within our buildings
um and we do continue to monitor those
and reinforce those measures with our
colleagues and partners
um and some of those uh measures include
um
retaining our occupancy levels within
our buildings making sure that we
are no greater than 40 percent we
monitor those levels as well
and we monitor those through our signing
in procedures that we have um as people
enter those buildings as colleagues into
those buildings and retaining those
occupancy levels supporters in
maintaining
our covered
measures that we have in place
face coverings are now mandated and this
is something that has changed from when
the
this report was actually put together
because of omicron and the developments
in relation to the variant so we're now
moving to essential wearing of face
coverings um and we're making sure those
are warm when people are moving through
the buildings and we recommend that
they're also worn within meetings as
well to support those measures
we're continuing to maintain space at
desks so we have our desks set up in
such a way that we can maintain space
when people are working within our
buildings and we also maintain space
within our meeting rooms by ensuring
that we have maximum occupancies to
enable that space to be maintained and
we're currently also requesting that
meetings are essential meetings only
that are taking place within our
buildings
we have increased cleaning regimes and
hand hygiene arrangements that we've had
throughout the pandemic
and we're also ensuring that we do have
good ventilation as well within all our
workspaces
ventilation being such an important
aspect of kovi control so that's a real
area that we're putting a lot of
emphasis on and we're supporting that
through
some monitoring using uh co2 monitors as
well that enable us to be able to look
at what the the level of ventilation is
ensuring that that's effective
and we've also to support staff and make
them understand and support them in
knowing what those covered arrangements
are particularly for staff who are
maybe having to come to the office for
the first time or haven't been to the
offices for a while we do also have a
mandatory trafford online kobe course
that we've developed
and that's now a request that all staff
actually go through that course to
remind them of what those measures are
that we have in place and we've been
able to share that course with partners
as well
support remains in place for staff who
are working from home
and we continue to provide
an update a range of guidance materials
provide access to relevant equipment
that's required
uh to ensure that staff do feel and
remain safe while working at home and
they also have the support of my team in
terms of any further complex workstation
assessment support that they may need to
support them in any health conditions or
other other service needs
and also as we're moving uh to this sort
of more hybrid working approach we are
currently updating our workplace first
aid arrangements at the moment as well
to reflect that hybrid working model so
we're ensuring that we do have adequate
first aid cover within our offices to
make sure we're meeting our compliance
responsibilities with first aid at work
legislation that's an important piece of
work we're completing currently
um in relation to schools
we are working very closely again with
schools and supporting public health as
well
we're providing direct support to
schools where they have
an sla arrangement with us
we currently have 77 schools who've
purchased our health and safety sla for
20 21 22 and we're providing a range of
support to those schools through things
such as a program of audits um access to
our school-specific guidance and
unlimited access to technical support
through our
senior health and safety advisors that
we have
within the team
and we can support on a wide range of
health and safety issues including
covered support
we're also assisting schools by
[Music]
regularly updating our um the the
coveted health and safety risk
assessment templates to support those to
support them in the the measures they
need to have in place to protect staff
and pupils from covid
and we also attend outbreak control
meetings where we're needed to help
support schools in how they manage
increased and elevated cases of covered
within the school setting
and we regularly attend um forums such
as head teachers meetings and meet with
trader union representatives as well to
answer any questions and provide advice
so a range of school support as well
so that just gives a brief overview
really of some of the support we're
providing as a team in relation to the
coverage space so i'll hand you back to
angela now thank you
thanks richard okay so i'll pick up the
update from here then so um i just want
to update you on a couple of things that
are happening
one of which is tomorrow so we have our
annual employee recognition and
celebration award our time to shine
ceremony is taking place tomorrow it's
another virtual event
um we're looking forward to celebrating
all of the amazing things that our
workforce are doing to support residents
to deliver excellent services to the
people of trafford
so this year's categories for
nominations are themed around our repeat
values and aligned to the corporate
priorities so we have eight awards
which are called empower people centered
inclusive leader collaborate new starter
covey champion climate action
and the epic team awesome award
the colleagues have voted for their
final epic awesome team for 2021 so it's
been a really collaborative process
we've received around 130 individual
nominations
and now all the finalists have been
identified the team has sent out the
event goodie boxes for all those
nominated and these include um a supply
of tea coffee hot chocolate biscuits and
chocolates and for them to enjoy while
watching the event tomorrow we're just
finalizing the music and we're looking
forward to celebrating our epic staff
who go the extra mile every day
so um just a few other updates um we've
committed to undertake um an engagement
survey again early in the new year
and we um did one with best companies um
in 2019
um and we've committed to resurvey the
workforce
um so we're going to promote it in the
new year now um we'll do a sort of a you
this is what you told us last time this
is what we've done since then you said
we did um and we'll really sort of
encourage colleagues to share how
they're feeling about working in
trafford so that when we launch the
survey around about february 2022 we get
um a higher um
engagement score than than we did last
time i think we got a score of those of
51 which was amazing for the first time
though i'll commit to undertaking an
update around the engagement survey at
the next committee in march next year of
the progress that we were making
in that space
so just a quick update on
apprenticeships and kickstart then so um
since the 1st of april we've had 43 new
starts um in the apprenticeship space 10
of these are in schools so we're
chipping away at our target of 56 for
council plane placements in 62 in
schools i have to say that it has been
impacted by covid
and our ability to focus attention on
this with the hr service working in a
number of different roles across the
year um but we do have a plan to push
the numbers uh and to increase the
numbers in in the new year
and with the kickstart um scheme as you
know we were successful last year and
we've we've had 13 until internal
placements with us
the first cohort of which are due to
graduate in december and there's an
event for them um taking place in in
december
so far two young people have attained
obtained roles here with us in trafford
council which is fabulous news
one has got a procurement role with star
procurement um and another is
going to undertake an apprenticeship in
business support within our trading
services team
we're looking we're currently working
with the other young people to find
future employment opportunities and we
have a few things in the pipeline or
we're supporting them with their
ambitions
after the placement some of which
involves for example going into
university
so we have nine young people from
traffic currently interested in our
cohort three
um after interviews that took place
today we think we can place a further
eighth
uh which is fabulous again and two um of
which are due to start with us
on monday in the economic growth team in
the place directorate so again you know
absolutely fabulous that we're giving
opportunities to traffic young people
um and supporting them with
a future beyond trafford if uh after the
placement they're
not necessarily
um wanting to remain with us
um i'm going to move on now to some of
the work that the team are doing with
social work and in adult services so
um we continue to offer a program of
support to our newly qualified social
workers in their first year of
employment
and that for them involves having a
protective caseload additional
one-to-one supervision and then
assessing them against the knowledge and
skill statements for adults so
catherine in the hr team and jane is
currently supporting eight newly
qualified social workers with two more
appointed but yet to start and again
when we come on to do the agency spend
up
and we'll we'll talk a little bit more
about some of the work that's going on
um in the children's space as well so i
think it's important just to say that
there is a lot of work going on behind
the scenes to grow our own talent in the
social work space so for example
we've got eight people in three cohorts
on the 30-month
social work apprenticeship program and
this is for staff in service to train to
be social workers in partnership with
manchester metropolitan university and
is via the apprenticeship route so we're
using our levy to good use in in that
space
so the team are also developing strong
links and with
trafford secondary schools so the team
in adult social care are delivering
sessions to increase awareness of the
roles that are available um in that
space with support from career
ambassadors for example
um and we're facilitating work
placements wherever possible within
schools so that they get a taste of what
it's like working for a local authority
and particularly in the health and care
space as well
so in children's services we're
currently supporting 17 new newly
qualified social workers with a further
two more awaiting a start date at the
time of writing of this update we've got
eight newly qualified social workers who
have completed the program and are
preparing for the final panel
which is going to be held in the coming
weeks
there's also seven members of staff
undertaking the social work degree
theory apprenticeship routes on three
cohorts and there's a regular program of
essential and mandatory one-day training
courses for children social workers and
a social care
offer
um virtually that via microsoft teams
there's also a big large-scale learning
and development program in place being
delivered by strengthening in practice
across all their areas of early health
and children's social care and and when
we um develop what we delivered the
agency spend update and jude can can
expand on on some of that in in the
update there
so we've also been working with an
external consultant from apsi
which is the association of public
sector excellence um and they have done
a review desktop review of all of our hr
policies from an equality's perspective
to ensure that we're doing all we can to
meet our compliance with with regulation
legislation
and our commitment to challenging
inequality discrimination and
disadvantage and particularly in the
employment field
so we have an equality steering group
set up with an agreed terms of reference
we've got quarterly representation from
our executive portfolio holder who's
councillors later
and with a cross-directorate
representation of senior management from
the council and the ccg
and we have one of the chairs of the
staff forums who attends on a rotating
basis
so the steering group meet on a regular
basis throughout the year
and the um one of their objectives is to
advise and oversee the emerging
equalities work program and action plan
that is being developed by an
operational working group
so what i'll commit to do is bring a
report to the next employment committee
of
some of the the work that's going on in
in that space and the next some examples
of which are um we
sort of refreshed our
edni sessions for managers in august
2020 as part of our wider epic manager
programme
um
and we've partnered with the
staff groups to review the contents so
that we reflect you know the aims of the
equality strategy and it's now open for
all managers to attend um
so the session explores for example our
own layers of diversity in relationships
it navigates through the concept of the
six signature traits of an inclusive
leader and how we can embed these into
our practice through a cultural feedback
and looking at everything through the
diversity lens
it's also
included in our values-based recruitment
sessions with a focus on the importance
of having a diverse interview
panel some awareness of biases that that
we all have during interview process and
on unreally just delivering a really
inclusive recruitment processes
process sorry and we've delivered some
of those sessions to our member cohorts
as well
so
i think we may have talked to you last
time about our approach to smart working
i think omicron made slowed us down a
little bit in that space but we are
because we as richard updated in the
beginning we were moving more to a
working from home position until we know
more about uh about that but we are
continuing in the background to embed
our hybrid working arrangements
supported of course and enabled by our
technology that continues to evolve and
working closely with our i.t colleagues
for just a couple more updates and
there's so much going on isn't there
across across the surface so we put in
place fluid vaccination clinics to
ensure that those colleagues who needed
to be fully vaccinated had the
opportunity to do so and we've supported
colleagues in the provision of adult
care services to be fully vaccinated
with their covid jabs in line with
legislation requirements now
in place
we're continuing
to support a wide range of services to
reshape and redesign
three of the bigger redesigns are in the
children's arena which we're now sort of
starting to work on phase two embedding
um what we did in phase one with the
main focus on two service areas we've
got no wrong no wrong door and early
help and the engagement sessions have
been completed
and we have an anticipated
implementation date
for first of april
2022
okay we've got an early years redesign
um in the planning phase as well and
that's a larger project and again
anticipated implementation date mid-year
2022 and we're continuing to work
collaborative with our manchester
colleagues supporting the ccg with the
transition to the new integrated care
system
and consultation has commenced for board
level roles across the system and we're
just in the process of finalizing the
data collection
and data cleanse needed to transfer
colleagues into that new
employment vehicle
from an internal perspective we started
to reshape the hr service and now
have one front door for all initial
inquiries that are triage fairy
telephone helpline or online portal
we're currently monitoring the
effectiveness of this and we'll be doing
a survey to managers in the new year
asking them for their views that will
then play into further reshaping of the
hr service offer and this is in line
with our aspirations to use our digital
capabilities better to get the basics
right of course
and to continue to upskill our workforce
and support our colleagues and our
services to transform
and reshape
we are continuing to support managers
and members in appeal hearings by
providing a comprehensive employee
relations service
we're continuing to revise our policies
to ensure they're still relevant fit for
purpose and legislatively compliant and
that keeps us safe from any potential
risk of employment challenge and
liability claims
so i'm gonna pause for breath now the hr
service as you can see continues to make
really great progress in achieving what
it's set out to in building a winning
culture and meeting our people strategy
commitments and there are around
attracting
retaining and growing talent
in trafford and keeping us safe as i
said early from any employment challenge
which is about developing our internal
hr staff too
and sustaining our ability to continue
to flex our resources demands flex and
change which we all know you know that's
been the norm for all of us now for some
time
i'm going to pause there so if anybody's
got any questions or reflections
take comments
thank you
is does anybody have any questions for
either richer
thank you very much for for that report
which is uh very comprehensive indeed
and
as you rightly said there's a lot going
on at this moment in time
in supporting our staff i just wanted to
ask
about the
uh support that's given to the uh social
workers because obviously
it's a key aspect of the work that we're
doing particularly
you know how we support them through
this uh
pandemic um
and
i think
um
looking at what you're doing the the
one-to-one
um support to
new social workers for the first year
do those
does that one-to-one support does that
mean that the trainers actually go out
with
the social workers for visits to clients
and things like that and what happened
in the second year because
you know it can be daunting when you
know you you you end that first year
with that kind of support
so it's really you know
those questions i wanted to
ask
is that for you anjali
thanks counselor um acton um
we i've got jude on the course i'm going
to bring jude brown hint as i say who's
the strategically practice improvement
and learning
but yeah we have a really comprehensive
learning office to offer sorry
counsellor acton that does mean that um
in the first year of supported um
employment
the individuals who are in that cohort
do you have a protected caseload they do
have a mentor from within the training
and development service or it could be a
mentor within their particular service
whether that's the adult service or the
children's service who does work very
closely with them on a one-on-one basis
so not only do they benefit from having
formal supervision from their um manager
but they also have um you know
additional support from within the
learning and development team
because it's really absolutely important
that you know we give them the
opportunities um for them to thrive and
and obviously you know undertake the
learning because they're doing it
obviously as part of their role but more
importantly be able to embed that
learning in in the service so dude i
don't know whether you want to come in
and probably expand in a bit more detail
thank you
good evening everybody um thank you yeah
i'm a strategic lead in children's as
angela said and part of my um
portfolio is around recruitment
retention and asyes sits in there so in
terms of our newly qualified social
workers it's exactly as angela's just
described so i won't repeat that but
there are additionalities so in the
first year there is also a taught
programme
of the year of supported um learning
um and in children's we have switched to
a different provider this year and we've
gone on a much more
um sort of practical basis so we've gone
with a provider who bridges that theory
from university to actually practice so
how do you deliver the theory into
practice because as you say it's quite
that step from being a student to a
newly qualified social worker with that
responsibility
we recognize it is difficult and the
other thing that we recognize that's
come up quite a few times already on the
call
is the impact of covid
because our newly qualified social
workers in the last 21 months have had a
very different experience than
pre-covered and what i mean by that is
the nut haven't been in the office
spaces with you know experienced staff
around them so we we've been really
mindful of that in addition to the
mention and the supervision and the talk
program and jane bonnell and that
angela's referenced um also does action
learning sets and with with our asyes
that's bringing them together doing some
collective learning and reflection
i had the privilege of going to the
session last week
which was great because it was very open
around what what excites them about the
role but also what are some of the
challenges and there was some really
good conversations
um and in in children's or asyes are
part of the strengthening practice
program as well so there's quite a lot
going on for them
um and there was a final thing oh that
was it the final thing that i was going
to say is and i think you've picked up
the point and perfectly counsellor acts
and what happens in the second year um
and in children's we are exploring what
that looks like for a second year
taking on board impacts covid again
isolation and working in very very
different times and actually now we
think the dfe are looking at this and
we're not doing it just to get ahead of
the dfe but we are looking at what a
second deported year would look like
because that's the right thing to do for
our practitioners
thank you
thanks for that
follow us sorry
sorry dave can i just ask for some
clarification from jude councillor acton
asked were newly qualified social
workers actually visiting families
unaccompanied or does that mentorship
mean that there's somebody with much
more experience that accompanies them on
these initial and follow-up visits jude
apologies
question that i was going to ask
apologies apologies
i'd got away with myself apologies so in
the short answer is that that will look
very different so in those initial
stages there may be some
co-visits with the mentor depending on
the experience level of the of the asye
because they might be newly qualified
but they might have long um experience
of maybe working in a children's home or
a different children's setting but the
expectation is is that the asye year so
moving from student to newly qualified
is a transitional arrangement so there
would be an expectation of quite soon
into the programme that they are
undertaking visits on their own but
that's with a mind to that they are
having the conversations with the mentor
of how that visit went what what are
they thinking what's the analysis of
what's happening for children and
families so i guess it's a bit of a
blended approach depending on the
confidence of the asye i hope that's
answered that question well it has to
some degree but it
um
you know i i do feel that
in that mentoring
period um
and you you you can't replace the
practical
you know with ever and any kind of
training you can never replace that
practical
um
you know
point in terms of
how you actually
you know are able to cope with
going into the house alone really and
and
i just
feel that we might be missing something
around that if we don't do that and i'm
not
absolutely convincing your answer that
that's what we do
so
i i it's just it's just my view
obviously i'm not an expert around
around this but you know
i do sit on the parenting board and
you know some
it's something that
you know is close to
my heart
and obviously the recent
you know case that that's happened
that's highlighted all of that
so it's just a point that i i know just
wish to me
i think one one of the things that also
um
might help with some i guess assurances
is we do look at the level of complexity
of work that our newly qualified social
workers do work with so we wouldn't
expect them to pick up high complex
child protection cases etc or cases in
court so we try and mitigate some of
that as well
okay
thanks jude i've got councillor
o'sullivan with a handout would you want
to come in councillor o'sullivan
yes
thank you uh councillor bennett just a
question um do we have bacons in the
social
workers and how money do we have thank
you
i'll take that one dude um yes yes we do
and i think
we may answer your question council of
sullivan when we come to do the agency
um spend reports um but i'll i'll take
that offline and i'll get you some more
detailed information that will sort of
give you a breakdown of the vacancies
that we've got at this present moment in
time but yes we do have a number of
vacancies
in the social work
world um
there is a reliance at the moment with
with agency uh and temporary members of
staff and and and you know we've we've
talked about this um in previous
meetings
um we're not alone um in in that
position um you know in speaking to my
colleagues across greater manchester it
is very much a a wider um position so i
just want you know to kind of make that
point i think at this time but counselor
sullivan i can get you some and further
detailed information but as i say we
have a report on the agenda um which
focuses on agency spencer some of your
questions may well be answered when we
come to that part the um the agenda
yeah
sorry can i just ask you well while
we're where we're on this subject uh
do we have any voluntary helpers say in
the you know in the background or in a
super
super supportive role where they could
help out obviously not on the front line
or anything but do we have have we ever
considered or do we have vacancy um
volunteers that would would help if
we've got a shortage of
social workers something to take
the burden off of them or you know
because then obviously
if we short stuff we would be they would
be under a lot of
pressure thank you yeah
yeah and we do have a volunteering
strategy um across um the system not
necessarily just focused in um the
social work um arena but
absolutely if there are any
opportunities to develop sort of
volunteering opportunities then we are
looking
to um to support you know services to
supplement um
areas of particular need i guess with
with social work and we need to be
really careful and and there is a a
process called disclosure and borrowing
so all of our um
people that work with with kind of our
vulnerable adults and children do need
to go through um the disclosure and
borrowing process so but that's not to
say that you know we can't not offer
those volunteering opportunities it just
makes it a little bit more complex i
guess to to bring them on board but
absolutely there is a volunteering
strategy um that we do
bring into play at certain points in
time
i suspect councillor o'sullivan
is thinking about retired social workers
with a lot of practice experience who
might be able to offer some time as
advisers to newly qualified social
workers without that authoritarian
worry for you newly qualified social
workers to say we haven't got the
absolute confidence and it's not always
easy to say that when it's
in to a direct manager so i suspect
that's what counselor o'sullivan was
looking at and i think it's something
absolutely worth exploring because i'm
sure there are a lot of social workers
out there who would be happy to share
their experiences and their history of
practice
how you actually go about doing that is
something else but i suspect that's what
council sullivan was referring to
thanks counselor bennett and yeah you
know we're looking at all different
aspects to
um supporting the delivery of key key
services um and as i said it's not just
a trafford um issue at this point in
time it is a much and and you know we've
we've talked about it haven't we
previously it is a much wider issue it's
a regional issue and it is a national
issue but absolutely it's it's a really
good um and valid point that that you
know yourself and councillor sullivan
have made um
and we we are looking at as i say lots
of different options to to think a
little bit differently so we'll we'll
factor that in as well into those
considerations councillor bennett
put your name to the list as well
does anybody else have any questions on
this item for richard or angela before
we move on to the agency spend
can't see any hands raised
right agency spend angela over to you
okay thank you so this report covers
quarter two it's a standard report for
july to september 2021
um i'm going to take the report as read
and i'll just pull out some of the the
key information
um i already mentioned i think in the
people update about the tightening of
the vacancy clearance process and that's
important just to just to say that we
are tightening it up even further um at
this point in time um we will go
straight into i think the um the
children's services um
part of the report and because as you
can see and you'll have read the report
in comparison to quarter one um agency
spend has further increased
um and the report states by 264
000 and this is because last month we
did under report
um the costs of workers we
onboarded through the social work agency
framework um and this is referenced in
the report in paragraph 3.2
so as you know i've asked dude um to
join us today and to update on some of
the things that are in place and in
progress
so um
and i think we're going to try and
upload a presentation um so at this
point i'm gonna hand over to jude and
she can sort of talk us through
some of those some of that thinking
thank you anthony
thanks jude
so i think we're gonna update uh upload
sorry
a presentation i think um
just while that is uploading this this
was a presentation actually that i
updated for a separate meeting last week
and when angela asked if i could come
along this evening and it was well timed
because it was here's one i prepared
earlier and so hopefully um that is
coming on screen soon
and whilst it is um sorry alex can i
just check are you are you going to
share on screen or do i need to do that
i'm sorry i was just struggling to find
the document
oh fantastic
thank you so much
okay
so the first thing to say is that we
have obviously had a task around our
recruitment and retention
of practitioners but this this will
focus very much on on social workers and
the social care
elements um and the first thing that we
decided to do was did recruitment and
retention really kind of cut the message
that we we wanted to get across because
actually what we know from our our staff
and sadly through exit interviews um is
that people um want to feel valued and
therefore our our stance on this is that
our recruitment and retention becomes
our investing in our people strategy
because we believe that that is really
critical
so if we just move on to the next one
thank you
so we've got four main areas of focus
within our strategy um and we've got
recruitment we've got retaining we've
got growing and developing and then also
we've got sustaining and we asked
ourselves some questions when we were
developing the activity and the work
that we were doing around so recruitment
what what is that and so that's
obviously about making trafford the
employer of choice uh we're in a highly
competitive market particularly around
greater manchester we're all kind of
fighting for the same sort of pool of
talent
so what makes trafford unique and what
makes people want to come to trafford
and retaining obviously how do we keep
people at what makes people stay in
trafford
the growing is obviously around how do
we help people progress
and what makes people enjoy the job what
gives them the job satisfaction and make
them want to get up in the morning and
come to work and then of course
sustaining once we've done you know all
of that activity how do you keep it all
going and how do you sustain a workforce
and how do we create those conditions
for practice to flourish and and
councillor action acton has already
mentioned around corporate parenting
board we know from our children and
families their biggest frustration is
the number of social workers that
they've had because they have to keep
repeating their story so our investing
in our people is not only around our
workforce but it's around our children
and families as well
so if we just move on to the next one
so i've put this in here apologies the
writing is really small hopefully when
you get it and you can zoom in on it but
essentially these are the conditions
of success
so it's a it's a theoretical framework
but we believe with having a mind to um
each of these elements that we will
create the conditions for success and
our redesign phase one the new
arrangements now in children's social
care and
are you you should be able to see in
there how we've kind of based that so
making teams small enough so that
practitioners and managers know their
children and families know their staff
having the visions and the values and
clearly articulating them and of course
we are nothing without a workforce and
so you have to have a focus on
recruitment development and retention so
that's what we're trying to create
through this strategy
next one please
thank you
so i'm just going to try and whiz
through um things that we've progressed
and things that we are still working on
so it's been an incredibly um active
piece of work
so we've request we've refreshed sorry
um in our recruitment
element
all of the recruitment material we have
completely rebranded refreshed our
adverts for roles for jobs
don't look the same as they did six
months ago so we have
tried to create it really um inviting
from first look so when people are
searching for jobs we want trafford to
jump off the page
we've we want to tell the story of
trafford and we want to tell the story
of children's services where we are in
our improvement journey how we're
responding to covid and critically
what's the offer if you come to work in
trafford so we've tried to really um
major on and the strengthening practice
unique selling point and i think the
other thing we've tried to do is
we want to work in a relational way with
children and families and we want to
work in a relational way together um and
what we've tried to do is
start that relationship from the time
that a person starts to read an advert
so for example we now have a personal
note from pamela what and our director
of early help and children social care
which basically is thanking people for
taking the time to have a look at the
advert and we're really looking forward
to receiving your application so we're
just trying to do things in a very
different way we have uh we are working
with an external recruitment um company
uh which is tripod and that is to focus
on our social work vacancies and as
councillor sullivan has asked do we have
vacancies angela i know you're going to
get the the numbers for that
what i would say is that um we have a
number of vacancies permanent on a
permanent basis but actually all but
four are covered by agency staff which
is why obviously the spend is reflected
in angela's report on that
and we know that we need to reduce that
we need to not just reduce the spend but
actually what we want to do
is create that permanence for children
and families and i refer back to
children's biggest issues are the number
of social workers that they have
we've also um implemented and
there's two things we've done around
sometimes recruitment is under your nose
and so obviously we offer student
placements for social work students
but actually we've implemented a student
pathway um to to an application to stay
in trafford because to have students
that is a huge investment of time and
for the university for the student and
for us
when people are coming to the end of
their student placement we have a
conversation and we basically say here's
an application form if you want to stay
then please fill it in and we
proactively interview and we've had some
success with that in the last recent
round of recruitment
we've also got our frontline programme
and our frontline programme is um it's
it's a two-year program for the first
year
the uh they're all post-graduates and
but for the first year they are students
and for the second year they have their
newly qualified year and they do their
masters
and what that brings is every year it
brings us six full-time permanent social
workers so we've continued to engage
with that frontline programme
and the other thing that we've done and
i'm sure this committee is aware of is
he introduced the market for supplement
so that is around our expert how do we
attract experienced social workers
well we have to be on a loving playing
field with within greater manchester and
that market force supplement doesn't
lift us um into a better region
and just the next slide please
thank you so what we still plan to do
obviously with the external uh marketing
company we want to ex have real exposure
in the marketplace we are in a
competitive marketplace
we want to target some of our
recruitment to make sure that our our
workforce equality and diversity is is
reflective of the community in which we
work
we also want to make sure that any
selection process
and interview um process
is actually reflective of our visions
and values and those relationships so
it's not just about having anybody it's
about having the right people that we're
confident can work with our children and
families
and i think angela's already uh
referenced this around you know swift
recruitment processes proactive making
sure that we're responding which i think
is is um we're in a good place with that
now
the next thing for us is about how do
you keep people warm so once you've
appointed once you've made that offer
how do we just keep that line of
communication going to make sure that
people that induction almost starts from
that point of offer so for example
invite people into maybe a team meeting
or to meet the team for a coffee or a
cup of tea or or um or a virtual meeting
as it may well be
and then the final thing on there is
again link to what um angela was saying
from within the adult space we've also
now made the links with colleges um and
some of the schools
and it's about extending the offer of
work experience and placements not just
in a social work space but of course
we've got a whole world of early help
children's homes youth engagement
so we've got our mind to
taking that recruitment even one step
further further back
next one please
so in terms of retention i'm not going
to go through these line by line because
there are there are quite a few but i
guess what i would say is that
our retention is really coming from a
real principle base again from from the
creating the conditions to success
what makes people stay
well what makes people stay is that they
feel valued they feel able to do the job
they're confident and they feel safe
so a lot of the the things on this slide
encompasses that so
induction if we get the induction right
people have a good first day then you
build on that from the foundations
supervision so one to one time with the
manager having a real critical um
reflection and supervision around
not just children and their cases in the
management of a plan but how are you as
a practitioner how are you feeling
making sure people take you know planned
leave that they're not working um too
many hours etc and
we've also looked at developing a
program of um that
and creating opportunities for career
progression now that might not be you
know the next job or the next layer up
but actually what are some of the
opportunities so we've had some really
lovely work recently from some practice
led improvement perspectives and you can
see people with the passion
that they want to do it and we've got
some very passionate practitioners in
children's services
and then i think as angela said the
biggest selling point i think for us um
is our strengthening practice programme
and so these are our relational practice
partners that we've commissioned and and
we are
just about to come to start the halfway
point of that program and we focused on
a real
care and confidence so actually you know
revisiting value basis you know what
makes us do the job that we do and i do
have to say it's been a real pleasure
sitting in some of those groups and
hearing the passion from our
practitioners you know some going as far
as the same i don't know what i do what
i'd do if i didn't do this job i feel
like i have to because i want to help
families so that's really positive
and then the next one which is probably
the last one i'm going to talk through
because i'm just conscious of time
and so again it's achieving high quality
first day so it links back into the
induction and we've also um which i
don't think i've said actually which is
a bit of an own goal because
and this is obviously around reducing
the agency spend but we are doing a
piece of work andrew and i angela and i
met recently um around what does that
offer look like how do we essentially
get to the point where agency staff want
to convert to be permanent here in
trafford so we are doing quite a bit of
work and analysis about what that looks
like
and the other thing about people feeling
um safe and supported in the work that
they do is being clear about what the
ask is being clear about our standards
of practice and which we've um
reviewed and
embedded into practice for our managers
to to ensure
are maintained
um
and i think well sorry the final thing
how could i forget i think there's
something about um celebrating our
successes it's something that we
sometimes don't do very well as
practitioners and managers so there is
something about recognizing there is
some fantastic work so how do we really
um celebrate that
and i think the final thing the promise
is the final thing
around retention that i would say is
that i think we work really hard at
developing the frameworks and again
creating the conditions for success
the next priority for us now is to
really start to deliver on that and
again
reduce the the use of agency staff to
reduce the spend but most importantly to
start creating that permanence for
children and i will just pause there
thank you
thank you
could i just come in on a couple of
points you've raised we're talking about
retention now do we do any analysis of
our retention rates now say compared to
10 years ago
do we have that data
or is that not something you just don't
have time to do or is that something hr
could help with
hopefully angela can come in and that
but do you want to yeah
do you want me to come in jude yeah um
we do have we will be able to get some
of that data councillor bennett i'm not
so sure we could go back 10 years
because our systems have changed
probably over that time but we've
certainly got the ability to to review
um
all of that information i mean what we
do do and you can come in as well on
this is we do do an analysis of leavers
so as people leave the organization we
do hold exit interviews with them to
understand you know the reasons why
they not always but we are starting to
sort of push
for that to be done in a slightly
different way now because it is
important it's really rich data i think
that we need to
to have to um as i say to understand
um
you know why people don't
want to to stay with us and it is always
for a variety of different reasons but
that then feeds into some of the things
that we're doing aligned to our
engagement piece so we you know it's
important that we do understand
um as i say the the reasons why people
stay and the reasons why people might
want to go
but yeah i'll take that offline
counseling and we'll yeah
sorry and note that currently if i've
read it right we've got 115 vacancies in
children's services what would be useful
is if we could have a breakdown as to
what categories is it primarily child
protection is it fostering an adoption
is it looked after children does it vary
across those different disciplines and
because that might give us some insight
into which areas we need to be focusing
on in terms of retention and support for
those staff
yeah we've we've got that data in in a
in a bit more detail so i guess for the
next report when we come to produce the
agency spend report what we'll do is
we'll do a supplementary
additional information particularly on
on children's services because we're
where i guess what we're doing here is
we're shining a light in
in there at this point in time so
absolutely i can take on take offline
you know your request for additional
retention data
and
provide some additional um information
that supports the different parts of the
service where the vacancies
might be
that would be really useful well thank
you i've got councillor sullivan with a
hand do you want to come in councillor
sullivan yes thank you chair i was just
and i think you've mentioned it briefly
um about the agency workers
do they be offered
a permanent job at trafford and uh
that's something i think you
you're looking at at the minute but it's
not always you know you've not done that
yet um so i think if they're trained and
they're they're good and you've got the
they've got the experience and it's what
you want and they're doing the job
uh and then you probably would have to
pay fees to the agency but
you've probably got vacancies if you
write on your hand that you could get
covered thank you
thank you so
um there's there's
two parts to that so one is through our
implementation of the redesign we have
done a bit of a a targeted approach of
when we've when we've looked at the
heads of service layers and then the
practice managers and then further down
we've gone through a very um clear
process of it was um um i can't remember
the word now redeployment or
assimilation for existing staff or
interviews and then what we did was we
invited our agents
agency staff to also
are you interested we did see some um
successes with that we had two um
practice sorry team leaders who are now
permanent practice managers with us and
we only have i think it's three or four
agency practice managers at that level
now so we have converted um quite a few
in terms of that
in terms of permanent and the next layer
we worked on was the advanced
practitioners and again we invited our
agency staff and we had some success i
think it was four or five and who wanted
to stay two permanently three on an
interim basis and that was due to
personal circumstances and now we're at
the point of the social workers and
inviting those we do have a breakdown as
angela said of all of the the agency
staff that we've got but also the length
of time that they've been with us so for
me the targeting is well if you've been
here for more than six months then let's
have a conversation so that's the next
bit that we're going to do
he muted joanna
sorry sorry
is there any further questions for jude
or angela on this item
can't see any other hands up
thank you both that was really really
interesting and i look forward to the
updates on this we're now going to move
on to the
uh quarterly report on exceptions to the
sickness policy i presume that's you
again angela
i'm going to hand over to beth norton to
do that update councillor bennett
good afternoon everyone thank you very
much so yes i've got a verbal report for
you on the exceptions that have been
received
outside of the normal occupational sick
pay that we provide to our staff so
during the last quarter um
july to september there were 10
exception requests that were received
and all 10 were approved so zero were
declined three of those were related to
covid or long covered specifically so
we're seeing increasing numbers
arriving
and the other sort of majority of the
requests that were coming through were
related to cancer cases tumors etc which
clearly have a long-term
requirement for recovery and the
treatment so obviously we wish to
support all of our employees who find
themselves in those scenarios
in terms of a breakdown of areas where
the osp exception requests were received
from
four were from children's three were
from adults and three were from strategy
and resource
thank you
thanks beverly any questions for beverly
on this item
no
thank you
you're a mute counselor bennett
sorry
i'm just thanking bev and saying what an
informative meeting this has been uh
there's no further items on the agenda
unless anybody's got any questions he
would like to raise
can't see any hands in that case thank
you all for your attendance and i'll see
you all in the new year
have a pleasant and peaceful christmas
bye everybody